I travel with with a little laptop the
smallest real computer I can get so 12
and something screen and so but what a
decent processor speed and where I am I
plug it into a dock and I use two
screens and such and then I network to
to any other resources I want if it's
all possible I would like to make that
machine smaller but at least lighter
large and lighter would be nice but I
don't get it and to light if you're
stalking a site in class seat on a plane
you still should be able to open up and
write and you can't do that with one of
those bodybuilders editions so a small
machine convenient machine that you can
carry with you and plug it into a bigger
system network to to more resources my
laptop is a the windows people always
ask that and they can't understand why
it's not my Linux well my Linux happens
to sit on my desk and it talks to our
traditional unix through it so i I used
both on a daily basis it's just happened
that it's easier to carry the the
windows box around
we are thinking real work goes on fairly
early in the day and then in the evening
no not really sort of thought work not
creative work I can I can polish stuff
I'm not a night bird like that I like to
think when I'm fresh
yes I have a mixture of stuff on the
computer just plug in the earphones and
and listen and there's a mixture this is
classical as a bit of rock there's a bit
of country it's it's quite surprising
what I can actually work with and what I
can't because it really does affect it
there's music that sort of takes a war
and you think about the music morale and
the code that's no good
and then there's music that you don't
hear that that doesn't help either and
well so so I found something that works
probably just for me but I like some
music